well u.s secretary of labor marty walsh
is in las vegas today
his focus the american jobs plan and its
impact in our nation's infrastructure
workforce and families bianca holman has
more on his visit
secretary walsh is no stranger to unions
especially like this one culinary union
2-2-6
prior to being mayor of boston he was
part of a labor union back east
secretary walsh took a tour of the
culinary academy of las vegas
he describes the importance of
retraining people many businesses like
the convention industry takes time to
rebuild and won't
really be in full swing until next year
so many hospitality workers are learning
new skills
and you think about convention center
businesses across the country
you know it's easy to shut it down
because it's you have to shut it down
it's harder to get it going it's like
kind of like an old engine getting it
cranked back up again
and but i do feel that you know
president biden is is
laser focused on getting our economy
going getting the economy cranking
wall says recovering from a pandemic is
unlike recovering from a recession
people still have health concerns
and child care concerns secretary walsh
says the president's investment in child
care for families will make a difference
bianca holman 8 news now